on ne vous le souhaite pas mais si un
jour vous commettez un crime ou un délit
il ya de fortes chances qu'on vous
soumettent à un prélèvement biologique
pas pour détecter si vous avez le coc
vide non plus tôt pour enregistrer et
stocker votre profil génétique ces
informations vous concernant iront
rejoindre un immense fichiers le fnaeg
le fichier national automatisé des
empreintes génétiques
or ce fichage il n'a rien d'anodin en
pratique la police relève aujourd'hui
systématiquement l'adn de toute personne
en garde à vue nonobstant la présomption
d'innocence qui est un des piliers du
droit pénal sachant que le simple fait
de conserver les empreintes génétiques
d'une personne est susceptible de la
stigmatiser ou de créer une
discrimination à son encontre se pose la
question de savoir si ces pratiques ne
constitue pas une atteinte
disproportionnée à la protection des
droits et libertés des personnes et
c'est bien pour ça que de nombreuses
personnes souvent des militants
politiques ou associatifs refuse de se
soumettre à ce prélèvement sauf que ce
refus est bien en réalité c'est un délit
passible d'un an de prison et de 15000
euros d'amendé et oui c'est prévu par
l'article 706 56 du code de procédure
pénal la peine et même doubler si ce
refus provient d'une personne condamnée
pour un crime hors du côté de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme on est
plutôt critique vis-à-vis de ce fichier
français des empreintes génétiques
aucune différenciation est actuellement
prévu en fonction de la nature et de la
gravité de l'infraction commise malgré
l'importante disparité des situations
susceptibles de se présenter et oui il
se trouve que dans cette affaire de
fichage tout le monde est un peu logés à
la même enseigne et ce quelle que soit
l'infraction commise
que vous ayez tué 15 personnes ou casser
un abribus paf quarante années
d'inscription de vos informations
génétiques fnaeg y compris si vous avez
participé à une manifestation non
autorisée certes un gilet jaune pourrait
vous en parler alors que cela ne
constitue pas en soi un délit justifiant
le fichage créant 98 de suite au meurtre
de guy georges le fichier national
automatisé des empreintes génétiques ne
concernait initialement que les
personnes condamnées pour des
infractions sexuelles depuis la liste
des infractions visées s'est allongée en
même temps que le nombre de personnes
fichées de près de 3000 à deux décennies
à près de 5,6 millions aujourd'hui dont
les trois quarts environ ne sont que des
personnes suspectées mais jamais
condamné est en réalité ces chiffres
sont virtuellement bien plus élevé cette
situation soulève également des
inquiétudes sur les atteintes à la vie
privée de personnes qui ne sont pas
directement concernés dont le nombre est
très important en effet la présence de
l'adn d'une personne renseigne de façon
fiable sur ses deux parents biologiques
ainsi que sur ses enfants le coefficient
multiplicateur entre le nombre de
personnes présentes et celle qu'il est
possible d'impliquer directement ou
indirectement et de 5,1 en incluant la
recherche en parentèle indirects ce
coefficient peut s'élever jusqu'à 6,2 ce
qui signifie que d'un tiers à la moitié
de la population française est
potentiellement identifiable via ce
fichier et l'exécutif ne semble pas
pressé de s'atteler à cette question
épineuse selon mediapart personne n'a
encore pris la peine de rédiger le
décret censé définir les conditions de
stockage des profils génétiques en
revanche les sénateurs de la majorité
présidentielle ont bien pensé à ajouter
de nouvelles infractions justifiant une
inscription au fnaeg puisqu'ils ont fait
adopter un amendement en ce sens il y à
peine de se mettre plus que jamais le
pacte républicain semble s'émousser dans
une ère numérique toute puissante et qui
ne cache plus ses tentations de fichage
tous azimuts quitte à renier sans
complexe sur les libertés individuelles